[Music]
hey everybody welcome to every damn day
today we have a special South Park
preview let's check it out
there he is dad how did it go
they voted keep striking there was a run
in violence between some of the strikers
in corporate they've decided to punish
us by taking our status
there's no easy way to say this so I'll
just come out with it and we're not
Amazon Prime members anymore then what
are we
everyone involved in the strike has been
dropped down one level from prime where
we're now Amazon USDA choice
okay at the risk of this sounding like a
commercial do you guys use Amazon Prime
yes yeah yeah what what about it is
great and why I use I have it I'm like
part of a family yeah I'm like I glommed
on to somebody else so I can like watch
stuff and get things to my house in two
days but I like going to stores well I'm
a little character I have no family and
prime is my family you know if you go
into someone's house you can go like
Alexa by this into the queue and then
check out see I don't like this I don't
know I don't like I like going to the
store now there's like delivery
groceries and stuff never will I have
delivery grocery I'm an able-bodied man
I can go get my groceries I like going
to the grocery it's great I don't want
to get delivery groceries ballsacks
no it's colorful you get to go in there
yes yes it's colorful thank you is an
Amazon screen house it's nice you get
the human interaction to complain about
like a good human interaction that's
where you get its fodder for
conversation my fear is that I'm not
sure if Amazon and all these big
companies like this are like job
creators actually or if they're like
actually just destroying the economy as
we know it
let's see the clip
[Music]
every day people are buying more and
more of them Amazon Google thingies
while we all sit here and lose our jobs
it ain't right
automated personal assistants
self-driving trucks whatever happened to
people jobs it's time for us to band
together and take to the streets to say
we're gonna take it no more no play der
Carter by Joni Mitchell
[Music]
you feel honored that South Park had a
character after you you think I'm the
guy with the red mustache I'm everybody
well you know what some of us have to
represent the common man I wish I could
wear overalls with nothing else oh yeah
privilege
I'll never but it's even it's like a big
male pretty like a big guy yeah I can't
do that I think you know I'll be
looking like gosh my gosh that's not
gonna work out man
Amazon is coming into New York and
Washington DC they're doing their agency
or two thing that's made a bunch of like
headlines and here's one of them
Amazon's as you said along the home
prices are skyrocketing whoa
skyrocketing sounds cool so is this good
are you happy
starting salaries are like 100k which is
kind of crazy so amaz what you paying
rent I pay there's just no way raking
Amazon if you're looking for someone
who's motivated works well individually
and on teams I'm available evil or are
they is this the new normal I would say
at this point everything is evil yeah
you may be something I'll tell you how
it's even oh this one's obviously not
evil the meat industry okay see that's
easy give me something that is nice this
program know what the big big big big
okay the Big Sister program is evil
because why is it just women helping
women shouldn't it be big sibling
program in fact that it's fostering a
gender divide and well we needed this
country is a fusing together so that
gender norms will disappear all right I
disagree okay Kellyanne relax there's
also a big brothers there's a there's a
big brother program to how the white get
they hang out together they do Brothers
and Big Sisters yeah we just call it big
family
st. jude's yes st. jude's yeah why does
have to be religiously affiliated mm-hmm
it should just be a hospital I think
your knowledge
Natacha vein blood she spins lies here's
a fun question how much money do you
think Jeff Bezos has what his net worth
is he need to get hair back Oh yep
that's true 80 billion was that a number
mm-hmm with $1 okay so we've got one
dollar eighty billion and enough to grow
his hair back and the winner is Hannah
he does have enough to grow his hair
back he has a hundred thirty nine point
five billion dollars what does that even
mean you know what what do you do
would that much money like even live in
New York for a year when I see a full
living room I'm like this is too much
too much how do you feel this thing I
don't really understand what you do with
it yeah yeah maybe I'm like being a
nearsighted idiot or something but I'm
like how do you just not give away 90%
of that well I guess he is trying to
start a health care thing no gates out
there curing diseases we don't care
about that guy anymore sexy enough to
him on the cover of a magazine
no thank you I was like the trending
story for a while Jeff Bezos is hot now
he like got jacked he's definitely the
creature of Amazon but speaking of the
Amazon let's check out this clip this is
now second any rain forest we are
entering notice the canopy of foliage oh
it's everything I ever dreamed it would
be
damn it's hot out here oh no that's the
same branch again no the rain forest is
very delicate and we must take steps to
protect here look these are squirrel
monkeys endanger inhabitants of the
rainforest Wow what the heck are you
doing I'm asserting myself it's tough
love does not make
when he's bad I say bad me to carry
smack him on the head
and here is a 3 throat slot I just can't
get over the 100 he's got like way more
how does Flint still not have clean
water you know what I mean I don't know
but they do have two days shipping
[Laughter]
so the Amazon itself just like the
company we don't know it's very
confusing there's all kinds of weird
stuff in there like this animal that
naydern showed us look at that thing
Amazon River dolphin and it's pink and
it's got a bottlenose and it's also yeah
it looks like a little kid drew a
dolphin like wrong yeah it's pink and it
has a long nose and his parents were
like okay that's fine it was like I will
make that animal that might be the best
creature in the Amazon but I think the
best creature is this one all right what
other cuts do we have to make to the
school budget next we have Tom Morris he
plays sexual harassment Panda at the
schools oh right we certainly can't
afford him anymore
I warn you mr. Evans Tom Morris takes
his job a little seriously
hello sexual harassment Cubs have a seat
mr. Morris whoo sexual harassment Panda
oh all right mr. Morris we at the school
board have been thinking and we've
decided that perhaps a panda isn't the
best way to explain sexual harassment to
children you see mr. Morris we believe
that a panda doesn't really have
anything to do with sexual harassment at
all I'm afraid we're just going to have
to let you go
I must why is the World Wildlife
Foundation evil yeah out world wildlife
why do we have to call it wild one
we treat these creatures like they're
savages you know if anything I think
they're very kind and polite and
well-mannered so really world wildlife
how dare you perpetuate an evil idea
when it comes to animals that was great
yeah that's really good speaking of wild
animals here's my dog with a mascot
there we go look at this we were a
baseball game and it was barking the
park they were you bring your dog and
this mascot bird thing that only has
this creepy smile expression picked up
the dog she did not enjoy that a human
like I can't even there you go I do love
her one paw that's just like the sexual
harassment Panda to let this bird figure
out what he's doing to my dog bird is
dirty as hell yeah lives in Coney Island
do you have a shout-out I know you do
it's on that card yes I do
our new episode of our sketch series
came out on Friday I share but I'm gonna
spin this chair
that's it all over your stop Jordan
Jordan and we got a comment from be
share that says this was funny but I am
deeply worried about whoever wrote it
and you know who wrote it be Cher it was
me baby so please check it out on every
damn sketch show show folks thanks for
watching this has been every damn day
make sure to check out our other show on
Twitter extra damn day and please like
comment and subscribe and send us money
send us money oh that's pretty
we take it oh yeah my memo is at Jordan
[Music]